[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce public
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité et qui se met au service des
citoyens nous sommes le lundi 5 décembre
et nous sommes ensemble pour une heure
et demie de débat et de décryptage au
sommaire ce soir ils sont tous les deux
qualifiés pour la finale je ne parle pas
de foot évidemment mais d'un autre match
celui qui oppose le député des
Alpes-Maritimes érections
Retailleau c'est de la s'affront pour la
présidente samedi prochain mais alors
au-delà de la question de casting à quoi
doivent s'attendre les républicains en
termes de ligne en termes de stratégie
en termes d'alliance ce sera le thème
principal de notre premier débat
politique notre second débat comme
souvent dans son public se veut décaler
de l'actualité du jour et nous nous
pencherons ce soir sur un mâle qui ronge
notre société la défiance scientifique
depuis la pandémie de covid la confiance
des Français à l'égarder chercheurs des
médecins s'effritent alors comment la
patrie Descartes et le pasteur a-t-elle
pu se laisser contaminer par le
complotisme par les fake news et puis
surtout comment y remédier ce sera le
thème de notre second débat mais tout de
suite place à notre premier débat ils
étaient trois la semaine dernière ils
sont deux depuis hier arrivés en tête au
soir du 1er tour Éric Ciotti entend bien
garder son avance sur son rival Bruno
retaillod mais une surprise est-elle
possible c'est un sujet de Jérémy
handsman
c'était un duel annoncé entre les deux
favoris
arrivé en tête du premier tour avec plus
de 42% des suffrages érectionti affiche
son optimisme pour dimanche prochain ce
résultat vient de tomber il me remplit
de joie de confiance d'espérance pour
aborder la victoire au second tour le
député des Alpes-Maritimes peut compter
sur le soutien de Laurent Wauquiez et de
plusieurs parlementaires qui se veulent
rassurant candidat sérieux les militants
le savent et donc voilà on est confiant
pour la semaine prochaine mais il faut
faire campagne encore
la victoire Bruno retaillot lui aussi
veut y croire deuxième du scrutin avec
34% le patron des sénateurs et l'air est
à moins de 6000 voix d'érections
non seulement tout devient possible les
dimanches gagne dimanche prochain je
gagnerai il mise sur un éventuel plafond
de verre atteint par son adversaire et
sur l'appui de poids lourds du parti
Gérard Larcher François Fillon et
désormais Xavier Bertrand surtout il
espère rassembler avec un meeting en
milieu de semaine nous défendons
justement un rassemblement de tous les
électeurs quel que soit leur choix de
premier tour autour d'une ligne de
droite clair assumée nous ce qu'on veut
c'est refonder ce parti politique parce
qu'on veut tirer les leçons de ce qui
n'a pas marché dans le passé pour
l'emporter chaque candidat sait qu'il
aura besoin des voix d'Aurélien Pradier
troisième avec 22% le député du Lot
revanchard s'amuse de son rôle de
faiseur de roi je voudrais remercier
Éric Ciotti et Bruno
l'élection pour la présidence DLR on en
parle ce soir avec mes invités des
habitudes sciences publiques j'ai envie
de dire la crème de la crème pour
commenter ce match au sommet bonsoir
Anne Vézina
constitutionnaliste j'accueille à vos
côtés Jean-Daniel Lévy vous êtes
directeur délégué d'institut Harris
Interactive Jean garrigue historien
président du comité de l'histoire
parlementaire bonsoir et puis notre
expert en communication politique et qui
m'accompagnera tout au long de cette
émission d'abord un tour de table est-ce
que ce résultat vous a surpris
journalière oui et non oui parce qu'en
fait on se posait la question de savoir
si ericoti pouvait passer dès le premier
tour restait une des interrogations
qu'on se posait des questions qu'on se
posait non dans le sens où quand on
regarde l'ordre c'est globalement ce à
quoi on pouvait s'attendre ça dire
Eric Ciotti en première position
Aurélien Pradier en dernière position et
entre les deux Bruno Retailleau est-ce
qu'on avait une idée précisément de ce
que serait le score précis de la part
des indécotes la réponse est non mais
globalement on se dit pas hier
énorme surprise au regard de ce qu'on
pouvait voir et puis déjà on regarde de
ce qui était les cartes qui existaient
par département quand on faisait
l'analyse on sait que c'est pas parce
qu'on rappelle que ce ne sont que les
militants qui votent absolument c'est
pas un vote des Français c'est pas un
vote des sympathisants c'est un vote des
personnes qui ont payé une cotisation et
que on avait déjà vu au cours du congrès
pour la désignation du candidat à
l'élection présidentielle que savait
fortement jouer là la première
représentation qu'on pouvait avoir d'un
point de vue géographique laissez
entrevoir que cet ordre serait celui-ci
puisque une des plus grosses fédérations
DLR c'est évidemment celle des Alpes
Maritimes de selles directions est-ce
que ça veut dire que le second tour est
joué d'avoir un sens pour vous
alors c'est compliqué de se prononcer
là-dessus parce que ça va aussi un petit
peu dépendre des jeux d'alliance on peut
toujours pas être à l'abri d'une
surprise d'un bon meeting qui amène à
fédérer autour de lui peut-être Bruno
retaillod néanmoins c'est vrai que s'il
devait y avoir surprises alors on avait
parlé de d'une victoire au premier tour
c'est habituel pour la droite il faudra
appeler Christian Jacob avait été élu
d'ailleurs dès le premier tour donc
c'est plutôt inédit qu'on est une espèce
de finale comme ça c'est c'est quelque
chose qui qui est assez en tout cas qui
qui peut être vécu comme une espèce de
défaite de la part d'Éric Ciotti mais la
surprise c'est risotti lui-même
finalement parce que finalement on se
rend compte que il fédère quand même
beaucoup autour de lui alors pourtant
qu'on nous le vendait comme une
personnalité assez clivante et c'est la
vérité puisque il ne fait pas forcément
l'unanimité de son parti autour de lui
et pourtant on a le sentiment qu'il a le
vent en poupe depuis le départ qu'il
fait la course en tête alors un petit
peu moins en tête d'après les scores
qu'on a eu mais voilà sauf surprise il
est quand même un petit peu considéré
comme le candidat naturel et c'est
plutôt ça qui apparaît surprenant je
pense par rapport à l'ADN de cette
droite alors rappelle que arrivé en tête
au premier tour ça veut pas forcément
dire arriver en tête au second et que
erikiotti on sait quelque chose genre
puisque les pays pour le savoir puisque
pour la candidature des LR il s'est fait
présidentielle à la présidentielle il
s'est fait coiffer au poteau par Valérie
Pécresse par la coalition de ces
adversaires que l'on voit en train de se
constituer alors de manière un petit peu
différente mais les soutiens qui vont
vers Bruno Retailleau peuvent laisser
penser qui pourraient y avoir en tout
cas pas forcément renversement de
tendance mais peut-être une modification
du rapport de force faut pas oublier non
plus qu'il y a quand même 30% des
militants qui n'ont pas ce sont pas
prononcé au premier tour je crois que
c'est à peu près ça 72% de taux de
participation voilà donc ils peuvent
éventuellement se reporter sur sur Bruno
retaillod mais ça c'est une hypothèse
non la vraie surprise ça avait été
justement que que Eric Ciotti émerge au
moment de de l'élection présidentielle
là aujourd'hui on s'attend un petit peu
plus à son discours on sait qu'il avait
verrouillé quand même sa fédération
épicée et puis quelques autres c'était
quand même le favori mais voilà moi ce
que je vois aussi dans ce résultat qui
n'est pas comment dire ça qui n'est pas
univoque qui est un peu voilà mitigé
c'est que plus que jamais il y a
plusieurs familles plusieurs courants de
pensée qui vont continuer à s'opposer
parmi les républicains alors on va venir
la question des lignes c'est quelque
chose par rapport justement à la
surprise qu'avait créé erikiotti c'est
vrai que c'était sur un côté très
radical et il a beaucoup modifié ce côté
radical parce qu'il avait dit je vote
Zemmour s'il est face à Macron pour la
présidentielle second tour il avait
parlé du Grand remplacement et il a
quand même changé son discours à en
souvient au moment de l'événement de
Grégoire de Fournas qui a dit qu'il
retourne en Afrique à l'Assemblée à
propos de l'océan Viking il a il a
condamné ses propos alors que Retailleau
n'a pas eu tout à fait la même aperçu
donc il a quand même un petit peu calmé
son discours pour se poser en
rassembleur en quelque sorte le fait
qu'il n'est pas d'ailleurs le fait qu'il
est condamné Grégoire de fondas
de la part des militants de sa propre
fédération alors il y en a un qui croit
toujours en tout cas c'est Bruno
Retailleau écoutez
souvenez-vous il y a quelques semaines
même quelques jours on nous disait
docteur que tout était déjà joué qu'il
n'y aurait qu'un seul tour tellement
c'était évident et bien non il y aura un
second tour seulement un peu plus de
5000 voix me sépare du score d'Éric
Ciotti et donc au contraire tout est
jouable et je vous
[Applaudissements]
alors tous les regards se tournent
évidemment vers le troisième homme le
député du Lot Aurélien Pradier on a déjà
écouté un petit bout de sa réaction tout
à l'heure dans le sujet mais je résiste
pas à vous la remettre parce que c'est
rare que les politiques fassent preuve
d'autant d'humour écouter sa réaction
hier soir je voudrais remercier enfin et
féliciter mais deux amis et concurrents
Eric Ciotti et Bruno Retailleau les
félicités pour leurs qualifications au
second tour et les remercier les
remercier pour toute l'attention qu'il
me porte désormais depuis quelques
instants les remercier pour les mots
d'encouragement de soutien presque
d'amour qui expriment depuis quelques
heures à mon égard que l'un et l'autre
sachent que j'y suis extrêmement
sensible
que traduit ce relativement score parce
qu'on rappelle quand même qu'il fait
près de 22 % qu'est ce que ça traduit
pour vous c'est c'est une demande de
renouvellement générationnel ou c'est
une autre ligne politique il avait
beaucoup de points assez originaux
Aurélien pradio et notamment l'idée de
la droite sociale c'est-à-dire qu'il
était tenant d'une véritable autre voix
dans cette coalition des droites plutôt
traditionnelles où on a Bruno Retailleau
erisiotti qui se ressemblent à ce niveau
là par rapport à leurs racines et
Aurélien Pradier qui joue cette carte là
déjà de du social de on s'engageant sur
des des points assez sensibles comme le
handicap le droit des femmes etc et
deuxième chose évidemment il n'a pas
hésité à jouer la carte du
renouvellement en disant d'ailleurs
lui-même le ras-le-bol de la droite avec
les anciennes élites avec les anciennes
familles a dit je veux être incarner
cette rupture donc donc c'est vrai que
ça faisait partie de ces points forts il
a plutôt un relativement bon score par
rapport à ce qui était escompté ce qui
prouve aussi qu'il a fait une bonne
campagne il faut savoir qu'il profite
aussi d'un débat qui a été à sa faveur
Assemblée nationale sur une proposition
qu'il a faite et donc il est
adopter la semaine dernière
exactement ce qui prouve qu'il est
engagé sur ces sujets et qu'il sait se
défendre au sein d'un hémicycle donc il
fédère autour de lui néanmoins c'est
assez drôle de l'entendre parler de la
réserve de voie puisque on le sait de
toute façon dans les 2e tour la réserve
de voie c'est tout à fait l'enjeu et ça
prouve aussi que on l'a dit il y a un
grand clivage dans les dans les
différents courants de la droite et où
va aller cette réserve de voir ça va
nous dire beaucoup de choses de ce que
la droite pourra faire demain ensemble
est-ce qu'on va arriver à à reconstituer
tous ces tous ces petits morceaux
d'identité c'est vraiment l'enjeu je
pense de de ce entre deux tours et de ce
deuxième tour aussi j'en garrigue
anne-charlaine parlait de droites
sociales c'est un oxymore ou ça veut
dire quelque chose à droite
historiquement c'est pas du tout en
oxymore parce qu'on a tout un courant
qui a incarné par exemple Philippe
Séguin son temps et qui était très
clairement axé sur le la question
sociale sur l'interventionnisme de
l'État les subventions au plus
déshérités etc il y avait et puis le
dirigisme aussi tout ça que constitue
une véritable famille et alors on
pourrait remonter au 19e siècle pour la
pour l'identifier maintenant aujourd'hui
elle a perdu un peu de sa signification
puisque il faudrait
solliciter rien à Pradier sur des enjeux
majeurs comme par exemple celui de la
réduction du nombre des fonctionnaires
celui de la question de la fiscalité et
notre est sur celle cruciale de la
réforme des retraites et voir si
véritablement là il a une petite musique
différente à faire entendre par rapport
aux autres dont on voit pas très bien
leur différence justement donc voilà il
faut quand même raison garder et voir si
ce ne sont pas seulement des effets
d'image et si ça représente
véritablement quelque chose de tangible
pour l'avenir alors on va passer aux
deux duelistes Éric Ciotti député des
Alpes-Maritimes Bruno retaillod sénateur
de Vendée je me tourne vers vous et
Jean-Daniel est-ce que les Français les
connaissent
pas vraiment mais favela plus que
l'autre enfin un petit peu plus un petit
peu plus un petit peu plus éructueux que
Bruno Retailleau mais on a regardé dans
les dernières enquêtes qu'on a été amené
à réaliser ils sont grosso modo
identifiés par un tiers des Français et
avec une petite prime à Éric Ciotti par
rapport à Bruno retaillod on a même été
regardé un peu plus précisément parce
que les Français c'est intéressant mais
ce qui va être le plus intéressant ça va
être l'électorat qui situe à droite sur
l'échiquier politique en terme de
notoriété il y a toujours le petit plus
en faveur d'erikiotti en terme
d'appréciation il y a toujours ce petit
plus également toujours en faveur
d'axioti mais on peut pas dire que d'un
point de vue d'opinion si vous me
permettez l'expression il tirer le match
donc ça ça voilà enfin il y a cette
petite prime à l'égarder mais pas
forcément en fait cette forme
d'engouement ou d'appui ou de soutien
populaire et qui serait assez qui serait
assez manifeste en gros ce que vous nous
dites si je comprends bien c'est qu'il y
a un Français sur trois qui les
connaissent il un Français sur trois qui
les connaissent et qui l'identifie et si
ce qui est pas si mal que ça enfin c'est
handicap
qui aimerait bien causer
oui j'aimerais bien disposer du même
taux de notoriété oui c'est un handicap
c'est un de dirigeable parti de
gouvernement quand l'inconnu c'est
handicap oui clairement et puis enfin
après si on regarde à l'heure actuelle
et si vous prenez la plupart des
responsables de formation politique vous
pouvez prendre chez Europe Écologie Les
Verts que ce soit il y a quelques
semaines ou encore aujourd'hui et vous
pouvez prendre même aux parties
socialiste même il y a quelques jours ou
quelques mois chez les républicains la
notoriété des dirigeants que ce soit par
exemple même de Christian Jacob était
pas aussi élevé que ça donc on est quand
même dans un contexte où c'est assez il
y a deux phénomènes qui sont
intéressants un on a des présidents de
parties qui sont pas très connus et pas
très identifiés même au sein de leur
camp politique et puis on a surtout des
dirigeants de partie qui n'aspirent pas
à devenir président de la République et
même à droite c'est quand même une forme
de nouveauté parce qu'en fait
historiquement on prenait le parti on
était le chef et donc naturellement on
était le candidat à la présidentielle et
là quand vous écoutez les discours aussi
bien d'Eric Ciotti que de Bruno
retaillod ils n'ont pas vraiment fait
acte de candidature pour 2027 en tout
cas c'est pire au contraire alors
indiqué qu'il serait vraiment président
de parti sans avoir la vocation à
devenir président de la promesse langage
que ceux qui les écoutent mais oui alors
juste une chose parce que c'est vrai que
quand on prend les ténors les barons de
la droite les Valéry Pécresse les
François Baroin j'en parle même pas
parce qu'il a il s'est mis un peu hors
champ mais Xavier Bertrand même Michel
Barnier Laurent Wauquiez pourquoi ils
sont planqués pourquoi ils ne sont pas
les gens alors il y a le cas de Laurent
Wauquiez qui est quand même à part
pourquoi parce que la candidature elle
est directement explicitement associée à
propulser à leur invoqué pour la
présidentielle de 2027 c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être une des raisons du succès
d'Eric ciotique c'est très clair quand
votant erikiotti à la présidence des LR
on encourage à une candidature de
Laurent Wauquiez c'est pas un manque de
courage de pas y aller soi-même comme
disait c'est vrai que historiquement la
droite le chef c'est toujours par le
chef le général Jacques Chirac Nicolas
Sarkozy
et ils deviennent candidats
effectivement ça indique aussi c'est
très important je trouve que ce cas sous
les dijones c'est que on est dans une
défection des partis politiques une une
sorte de méfiance à ta vie des Français
vis-à-vis de du rôle des parties alors
se méfie aussi des institutions des
acteurs politiques en général mais les
partis politiques aujourd'hui sont
complètement discrédités et c'est
pourquoi alors leur leader perce très
peu ne sont pas visibles audibles par
par les Français et puis c'est peut-être
aussi la raison pour laquelle mais ça
c'est lié à notre mode de la
surpersonnalisation de notre vie
publique par la présidentielle c'est la
raison pour laquelle ceux qui veulent y
aller ne passent pas par la case partie
c'est à dire qu'il passe par la case
opinion d'abord la case opinion ou alors
il crée leur propre partie c'est un duel
de second couteau
c'est un duel de second plan en effet
par rapport rapport à ce qu'on a dit du
véhicule qui est le parti politique
c'est-à-dire qu'on a quand même le
sentiment que c'est encore une écurie
surtout sur des parties qu'on a appelé
pendant longtemps les parties de
gouvernement qui ont été nos parties
historiques que ce soit LR ou le PS on
peut pas demain perdre l'identité
complètement de ces parties-là
évidemment il continueront à avoir un
poids mais comme on l'a dit la
présidentielle on a le sentiment qu'elle
ne se joue absolument plus à ce niveau
là et donc l'idée d'avoir le ticket
gagnant Éric Ciotti Laurent Wauquiez
c'est un inédit absolu de la Cinquième
République surtout pour ce parti-là mais
ça prouve en quelque sorte que on garde
au chaud les candidats pour la future
présidentielle parce qu'il ne faut pas
les exposer trop vite il y a aussi une
opinion qui est de plus en plus en
changeante des sujets très inflammables
sur lesquels plus tôt vous vous
positionnez plus vite vous pouvez
griller des cartouches et donc en
quelque sorte il y a cette idée que plus
tard on y va et bien mieux c'est en
quelque historiquement il y a qu'un
parti qui tentait ça c'était les écolos
on peut pas dire que ça devrait ici
jusque là en tout cas
91.000 militants près de 66 000 votants
c'est quand même très fois plus que les
écologistes auxquelles je faisais
allusion elle est pas mort non elle est
pas mort quand vous regardez c'est
encore une formation politique et qui
détient la plupart des régions qui est
présente dans les départements qui
détient un centre de grande ville de
France qui a un cercle militant ou en
tout cas un cercle qui est aux
responsabilités de manière directe ou
indirecte donc faut considérer ça comme
étant une formation politique qui est
encore ancrée dans les territoires et
même quand vous regardez les députés LR
localisation géographique montre bien
qu'ils ont encore un espace sur
l'ambiance qui est importante et même
parfois dans les territoires qui sont
les territoires plutôt plutôt ruraux
donc c'est LR est encore présent est-ce
que LR est audible ça c'est peut-être
une autre question
et que quand vous interrogez en fait les
citoyens sur ce qui s'est passé au cours
de ces six derniers mois ils n'ont pas
véritablement entendu les répliquer une
prennent pas vraiment très bien la ligne
politique et même ce qui n'est pas une
intéressant parce que je sais pas si ça
a été fortement souligné si on demande
et si on met à côté le programme
politique d'érection et le programme
politique de Bruno Retailleau on peut
pas dire que ce soit une confrontation
de ligne extrêmement marquées autant
justement il y avait des différences
avec ce qui était indiqué de la part de
d'Aurélien Pradier mais là globalement
on est parfois dans l'épaisseur du trait
pour essayer de voir justement ce qui va
être amené à distinguer l'un de l'autre
si ce n'est peut-être de manière
sous-jacente des écuries présidentielles
qui commencent à se dessiner d'un côté
Éric Ciotti avec Laurent Wauquiez et
puis vous l'avez indiqué dans le cadre
du reportage Bruno Retailleau avec
d'ailleurs Xavier Bertrand qui soutient
le candidat de Vendée alors tonton
justement l'exercice quelle droite
représente
Eric Ciotti alors c'est c'est Éric
Ciotti a beaucoup aussi il était Sarkozy
c'était une époque on va dire que il a
démarré dans l'ombre de Christian
Estrosi il faut le rappeler
avec lui mais ça c'est la politique mais
mais oui saline c'est quand même celle
d'une droite populaire
identitaire sécuritaire c'est assez
clair pardon pour toutes ces
allitérations n'est-ce pas mais voilà on
a on a on a une ligne qui est assez
identifiée qui le rapproche
idéologiquement à la fois de Marine Le
Pen et d'Éric Zemmour d'où les
tentations comme ça de
rapprochement voire de constitue une
sorte d'alliance des droites ce qui est
le ce qui était le souhait aussi de
Zemmour et de Marion maréchal enfin il y
a une droite quand même assez clairement
identifiée qui en réalité à mon sens ne
correspond pas du tout à l'ADN de la
droite c'est on va vers une un type de
droite qui ressemble le plus à la
tradition de l'extrême droite je dis pas
que c'est aujourd'hui de l'extrême
droite mais ça correspond plus à
tradition de l'extrême droite tandis
qu'avec Bruno Retailleau on a une
dimension d'abord catholique
traditionaliste
conservatrice qui correspond plus à une
des traditions une des familles de la
droite mais c'est vrai que par ailleurs
on voit pas très très bien ce les
différencier sur les sujets majeurs de
personnalité davantage qu'un une
confrontation de ligne politique
peut-être de style en effet en quelque
sorte moi il y a quelque chose auquel je
pense c'est le caillou dans la chaussure
de Nicolas Sarkozy pour Éric Ciotti
puisque en effet il est Sarkozy St
plusieurs fois il s'est revendiqué de sa
ligne on considère que ils ont ils
continuent à entretenir de bonnes
relations on a bien vu à l'inverse que
Bruno Retailleau lui ne se privait pas
de parfois tacler complètement le bilan
et la personne voilà en tant que la même
dit qu'il n'aurait aucune sensibilité au
fait qu'il quitte le parti donc voilà
les mots sont jetés alors pourtant
qu'erisiotti justement c'est l'anti
alliance avec l'arène que pourtant
Nicolas Sarkozy continue de marteler
donc il y a ce paradoxe qui va devoir
être réglé entre personnes et dans la
ligne de ce que va être la future droite
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on penche plutôt
vers l'arrêt est-ce qu'on penche plutôt
vers l'extrême et est-ce qu'on garde son
identité en tant que tel alors
erisotti Bruno Retailleau aurait rien
pradie ont tous été très clairs sur
l'idée de garder l'ADN mais montrer que
pour erisiotti va quand même falloir
solutionner ce paradoxe ontologique
autour du Sarkozy ce sont quand même
deux droites très conservatrices à
droite pas très libéral pas très porté
sur un discours économique plutôt porté
sur un discours parce que vous avez
parce que cet espace-là on sait bien
aujourd'hui qui qui le remplit on va
dire du côté de d'Emmanuel Macron du
côté de la droite de ce qu'on appelle la
macronie il y a Edouard Philippe qui se
positionne sur ce terrain là et puis
regardez dans les principaux ministres
d'Emmanuel Macron Bruno Le Maire Gérald
Darmanin ce qui veut dire que eux aussi
ils sont sur les starting blogs pour
2027 et ça représente et il représente
cette droite libérale conservatrice qui
qui est une vraie tradition là aussi
parler d'orléanisme à une époque on
verrait un Bruno Retailleau plutôt
légitimiste du fait de son intérêt pour
la tradition etc et puis éventuellement
en érection type dans ce Bonaparte enfin
c'est un bonapartisme qui qui l'orne
vers je répète vers l'extrême droite ce
qui était assez flagrant surtout dans
cette campagne c'est qu'il y a pas
d'idées nouvelles en fait ça fait des
années que les républicains n'ont plus
d'idées nouvelles donc on est sur
l'immigration la sécurité le régalien un
peu sur le social avec Aurélien Pradier
mais il y a rien il y a rien de neuf
donc pas de figure vraiment qui qui qui
qui se détermine comme ça naturellement
pris en étau entre l'extrême droite et
Macron et en plus aucune idée nouvelle
il y a du travail franchement avant 2027
peut-être juste sur la proposition
d'eriki sur l'héritage en fait qui était
un point qu'on n'est pas forcément
entendu par le passé et qu'il a indiqué
par le passé et qu'il a à nouveau
j'ai deux questions pour vous
Jean-Daniel est-ce que pour vous ce
rapprochement des lignes au fond c'est
le signe d'un rétrétisme d'un
rétrécissement pardon ou d'une
clarification
le rétrécissement a lieu objectivement
quand vous regardez le nombre de
militants aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qui pouvait exister il y a encore une
dizaine d'années voir il y a 5 ans il y
a quand même une baisse du nombre de
milit clarification c'est le cas aussi
parce qu'en fait on peut pas dire qu'il
y ait un affrontement net au sein de ce
de ce débat
pour un parking
c'est c'est en tout cas une demande qui
est effectuée en fait de la part des
Français en disant on peut
éventuellement être en désaccord avec
vous mais on va au moins comprendre ce
que vous dites donc au moins si c'est
clair ça apparaît comme étant une forme
de sincérité du du propos jusqu'à
présent en fait cette forme de clarté
elle se traduit pour partie dans les
alliances on l'a vu en fait pas
d'alliance avec le RN pas d'alliance
avec Emmanuel Macron et ses formations
politiques mais dans un mélange les
clarté en termes de proposition et
d'orientation ne sont pas clairement
identifiées sachant que à droite en
général on choisit d'abord un chef et
puis après on va être de pouvoir adorer
adhérer à ses idées celles-ci sont pas
entendu juste une deuxième question pour
vous puis après je vous passe la parole
en Charlène est-ce que cette ligne
conservatrice de droite je sais pas
comment on dirait est-ce qu'on peut dire
réactionnaire on va réactionnaire en
tout cas sécurité
identitaire est-ce qu'elle toute
majoritaire politiquement en France
est-ce qu'elle peut être majoritaire
sociologiquement en France
historiquement je crois que la droite
n'a jamais été seule majoritaire elle a
toujours du faire de manière ou d'une
autre des alliances notamment en général
avec des formations de centre droit
alors actuelle ça n'en prend pas
véritablement le chemin et même quand
vous prenez différentes formations
politiques comme l'UDI celle-ci en fait
à plutôt tendance à se rapprocher de
d'Emmanuel Macron et de ses formations
politiques que de la droite
traditionnelle donc ça montre bien qu'il
y a une nécessité peut-être que le
principal enjeu ça va être une bataille
comme c'est souvent le cas une bataille
culturelle pour arriver à imposer les
thématiques on sait que sur les
thématiques de sécurité d'autorité et
voire même de reconnaissance de la
valeur travail ils ont potentiellement
une écoute qui peut être relativement
importante et qui traverse une partie
d'opinion on parle d'une droiteisation
d'une partie importante des françaises
qui est pas tout à fait faux mais ça ne
se traduit pas aujourd'hui donc ça se
fournit forcément par étape mais en tout
cas à l'heure actuelle qui peut
envisager gagner seul une élection je
crois que quasiment aucune formation
politique désespéré en tout cas il y a
une droitisation de lr.i.r le maire de
La Baule qui est pas à gauchiste patenté
c'est Franck lourier l'ancien conseiller
de Nicolas Sarkozy parlez lui d'un
risque de melonisation en faisant le
parallèle avec le Georgia Meloni oh la
première évidemment après la présidente
du Conseil italien c'est excessif pour
vous de toute façon les comparaisons
internationales en soi Noval que pour
ceux qui s'engagent dans ces dans ces
droitisation en effet la droitisation la
question des coalitions je pense que la
mélodonisation c'est un peu cette idée
aussi de savoir si on se rapproche de
l'extrême droite pour faire alliance
avec elle c'est c'est ça l'enjeu
évidemment on a le sentiment que le
candidat le mieux choisi pour ça cette
Éric Ciotti néanmoins ce qui est
intéressant de dire c'est qu'on a parlé
de de ces discours de droits
traditionnels qui reviennent c'est un
souhait de l'électorat et c'est pas
tellement un souhait électorat mais
c'est en réalité l'électorat qui remet
les questions les plus traditionnelles
on a parlé parfois du caractère un peu
ronflant des questions qui sont dans le
débat public mais elles sont remises
dans le débat public par par
oui une sensibilité de l'électorat à ces
questions de nation de représentation de
la France à l'international sur la
question de l'immigration il y a tout ça
qui devient de plus en plus prégnant
parfois un peu violent aussi dans les
positionnements qui sont attendus on
attend en quelque sorte une forme de
radicalisation du discours politique et
c'est là qu'elle est finalement à
quelque chose à jouer alors est-ce
qu'elle est seule peut encore quelque
chose sur ce plan de droite de la droite
c'est la question qu'il faudra se poser
il faut rajouter aussi quand même que LR
à un poids qui n'est pas uniquement par
rapport à son ancrage local elle a cette
formation à un poids important d'un
point de vue institutionnel que Bruno
Retailleau matérialise bien qui est le
caractère d'opposition au Sénat alors
certes ça paraît un peu institutionnel
quand on dit ça c'est la constitutionnel
ce qui parle mais au fond ça donne
beaucoup d'importance rejet des projets
financiers ces dernières semaines rejet
de la plupart de certains textes qui ne
conviennent pas à cette opposition
ou co-construction exactement ce qui
prouve que LR peut tout à fait jouer la
cheville alors on va rappeler le
contexte parce que vous venez de le
faire LR c'est quand même trois
présidentielles perdus de façon
consécutive dont les deux dernières dès
le premier tour c'est quand même un
maigre score législatif avec 62 députés
derrière le rassemblement national qui
en compte 89 mais c'est vrai que c'est
aussi le Sénat avec le premier groupe
145 sénateurs LR serait devenu un parti
territorial genre un peu comme un pull
devenir le Parti radical le parti sont
mortels on le sait c'est effectivement
incontestablement une des directions qui
a été prise d'ailleurs le fait que
Gérard Larcher président du Sénat soit
devenu un personnage essentiel dans
cette organisation des des trois droites
c'est quelque chose qui traduit ça parce
que lui c'est l'homme des territoires il
le surigne il le Martin le Sénat c'est
la chambre des territoires et les
républicains majoritaires au Sénat sont
le parti des territoires ce qui peut
d'ailleurs être le le ferment le
fondement d'une éventuelle refondation
c'est c'est tout à fait pas possible de
se de se construire là-dessus d'ailleurs
vous avez parlé du Parti radical il
s'était précisément construit construit
là-dessus à l'époque donc c'est tout est
possible mais ce qui est le plus
probable à l'heure actuelle étant donné
à configuration étant donné la culture
politique représente les républicains à
mon sens c'est que d'une part tout ce
qui concerne l'identité le souverainisme
la sécurité soit des thématiques qui
sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus
phagocytée par le rassemblement national
et que d'un autre côté le libéralisme
tel que que peut éventuellement Bruno
Retailleau l'incarné mais cette droite
libérale elle est aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus incarnée du côté soit de Emmanuel
Macron soit de Edouard Philippe donc il
y a quand même un gros risque de de
d'écarter
de prix sur Internet parce que cet
écartellement repose sur des bases
idéologiques et c'est ça qui est quand
même inquiétant on se souvient de ce que
disait Jean-Luc en 2017 à propos du
Parti socialiste c'est ce qu'il faisait
beaucoup rire à l'époque il y a un petit
air de panique disait-il c'est comme le
casse-noix faut que ça sert des deux
bords Macron et Mélenchon et au milieu
ça fait de lui et on peut se demander si
c'est pas la même chose qui est en train
d'arriver à LR avec Macron d'un côté et
puis Zemmour et Le Pen de l'autre en
tout cas il y en a qui scrute cette
élection de très près on parlait des
alliances tout à l'heure ce sont les
sénateurs centristes comme la relevé
l'excellence Steve Jourdain bonsoir
Steve
alors est-ce qu'on est à la veille d'un
grand chambardement ici au Sénat c'est
possible Mathieu c'est possible en tout
cas vous l'avez dit dimanche le score de
l'élection sera scruté de très près au
cœur des balles à venir même du groupe
LR présidé par Bruno Retailleau écoutez
par exemple Mathieu ce que disait le
sénateur Alain jolandet la semaine
dernière il soutient Éric Ciotti il
s'adressait au sénateur Stéphane
leraudellier qui lui est plutôt dans la
team Bruno Retailleau écoutez
profondément renouvelé on peut pas voter
des lois puisse excuser un mois après
parce que parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'elles sont pas bonnes je rappelle ce
qu'on a fait sur le covid bah oui on a
voté le past sanitaire puis après en
même temps on a voté une commission
d'enquête
et si on veut faire une si on veut faire
une introspection
puisque tu es favorable aux
introspections faisant celles aussi du
Sénat ambiance ambiance difficile de
prévoir un si un éventuel échec de Bruno
Retailleau dimanche aura des
conséquences immédiates sur le groupe L
ce qui est sûr c'est que certains Paris
déjà ici sur une recomposition
progressive de la majorité sénatoriale
dont les composantes ont parfois du mal
à s'accorder ces derniers temps vous
voyez on rappelle que la majorité au
Sénat c'est 145 sénateurs LR plus 57
sénateurs du groupe centriste autrement
dit sans les centristes pas de majorité
pour la droite et on a constaté
récemment quelques divergences entre les
deux groupes par exemple quand les
sénateurs LR demandent un droit de veto
pour les maires en matière
d'implantation d'éoliennes les centrices
disent niet résultat la droite a dû
renoncer à sa mesure et accepter un
compromis avec le gouvernement compromis
que les députés LR à l'Assemblée
nationale eux ne veulent ne veulent pas
en fait ce qui est en jeu c'est latitude
à adopter face à Emmanuel Macron
certains sénateurs centrist ne sont pas
contre une alliance Nicolas Sarkozy on
sait qui est lui clairement favorable
pour l'ensemble de la droite mais pour
l'instant Gérard Larcher ne veut pas en
entendre parler écouter
ça y est c'est se diluer
c'est disparaître c'est de plus avoir
d'identité ça va être notre défi je n'ai
pas dit qu'il était simple notre défi
c'est de retrouver la confiance des
Français leur dire qu'il y a une autre
alternative que de finir dans un score à
l'italienne ou à la suédoise une date à
avoir en tête Mathieu septembre 2023
date des prochaines élections
sénatoriales c'est peut-être à ce
moment-là que débutera la grande
recomposition à la Chambre haute
plusieurs postes clés seront remis en
jeu et certains sénateurs centristes
notamment pourraient être tentés de se
rapprocher de la majorité présidentielle
merci beaucoup Steve alors vous en
disiez un mot évidemment Nicolas Sarkozy
qui lui pousse à une alliance avec
Emmanuel Macron il a remis hier quelques
jetons sur cette sur cette hypothèse
j'aime les militants des républicains je
leur dois beaucoup a-t-il dit je serai
toujours là pour eux mais je ne suis pas
prisonnier ils ont le droit d'avoir leur
opinion moi la mienne et d'enfoncer le
clou pour une alliance avec Emmanuel
Macron je pense qu'Emmanuel Macron
devrait tenir compte de tous ceux qui
n'ont pas voté l'émotion de censure
passionné par rien leur chef de l'État
estime que même s'ils ne sont pas 100%
d'accord c'est l'abaque se joue dans
l'avenir est-ce qu'il a raison pour vous
j'en ai donné le devis il a raison de
dire ce qu'il pense déjà
et enfin
c'est que aujourd'hui en fait Nicolas
Sarkozy a un poids politique est quand
même moins important que par le passé
tel point que on a même plus entendre le
taillot qui a dit en fait qui voulait
quasiment des sarkozymes en fait sa
formation politique ce qui est un acte
de rupture auquel on aurait même pas pu
penser il y a encore trois quatre ans
donc on est plus le grand mamamucci de
la droite
le sentiment que il aurait pu jouer un
peu plus l'appui à l'égard de Valérie
Pécresse quel que soit le ce qui peut
être
absolument et que il aurait pu pousser
un peu plus voilà les candidats
républicains on peut même rappeler que
dans le cas des législatives il a
soutenu des candidats qui étaient
proches d'Emmanuel Macron voire même
contre des candidats LR avocat il y a ce
point là après il y a toujours une
question stratégique qui se pose
aujourd'hui pour les républicains
auxquels ils ne parviennent pas à
répondre vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
en fait du casse moi avec lui le qui se
retrouvait au milieu par rapport au
Parti socialiste ils sont exactement
dans cette situation là mais elle est
pas si nouvelle que ça si vous regardez
les dernières élections européennes
notamment en fait avec la candidature de
François-Xavier Bellamy un score de 8%
dont certains pensaient qu'on était
vraiment arrivé au niveau plancher de ce
que vous pouvez peser les réplicants on
a vu par la suite ce que
cet électorat qui a exactement été dans
cette configuration l'électorat qui a
évoqué pour François Fillon on peut
rappeler qui pesait 20% à la
présidentielle
a pour une partie non négligeable votée
pour la liste qui était soutenue par
Emmanuel Macron et pour la même
proportion voter pour la liste qui était
soutenue par Marine Le Pen le reste
étant resté auprès de l'épure de ceux
qui disaient je suis droit tu proche des
réplicans et quoi qu'ils disent de toute
façon je voterai pour eux donc c'est pas
une situation qui est une situation
nouvelle c'est une situation qui s'est
déjà créée par le passé qui s'est déjà
créé dans le cadre du premier
quinquennat auquel les républicains ne
sont pas parvenus à pouvoir répondre
alors même qu'ils avaient une formation
politique qui était bien plus imposante
à l'Assemblée encore aujourd'hui et donc
là ils sont véritablement pris en étau
avec une difficulté tant qu'il n'arrive
pas à affirmer précisément ce qu'ils
sont en tout cas qu'ils arrivent à être
entendus de manière suffisamment forte
la question des alliances à mon avis
après sera secondaire d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont plutôt en
position de faiblesse comme position de
force pour pouvoir imposer leur point de
vue en tout cas d'un point de vue
d'opinion alors pour l'instant un des
principaux intéressés dans cette partie
de recomposition mais c'est Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron il sort d'une
séquence internationale et il tente de
rassurer les Français sur d'éventuelles
coupures de courant mais oui parce que
depuis quelques jours on entend parler
que de ça les éventuels coupures
d'électricité au mois de janvier le
gouvernement compte s'y préparer et pour
ce faire fin novembre donc Elisabeth
borne a transmis au préfet une
circulaire de près de 10 pages qui
détaille toutes les démarches à suivre
en cas de coupure un plan d'action qui
est décliné ensuite par ministère et
administration pour prévoir jusqu'à la
manière de réchauffer les plats des
résidents d'epad donc c'est des dessins
détails sûrement très utile pour la
suite on a suffisamment critiqué le
gouvernement pour son manque
d'anticipation pendant la crise covid
pourquoi
les féliciter là cette fois-ci il y a
notamment les plis ecowatts quand même
assez pratique pour suivre l'état des
lieux de notre consommation d'énergie et
réduire éventuellement la voilure si
c'est au rouge mais alors ce scénario il
est très trop réaliste mais il est
tellement concret qu'il en devient quand
même assez réaliste et il crée il a créé
en tout cas une forte inquiétude face
aux dysfonctionnement que ces coupures
d'électricité pourraient occasionner
plus d'écoles le matin les
télétravailleurs du temps du covid il se
souviennent la galère que c'est de
travailler avec les enfants à côté à la
maison plus de services surtout sans
électricité si on a froid service
téléphonique plus de services
téléphoniques alors on aura le numéro
d'urgence le 112 quand même faut se
rassurer et du coup face à cette montée
d'angoisse c'est le président de la un
public lui-même alors en déplacement aux
États-Unis qui a voulu calmer le jeu
samedi dernier lors d'une interview pas
de panique nous dit-il en marge de sa
visite à Washington ça ne sert à rien il
y a un travail fait par le gouvernement
qui est légitime pour préparer un cas
extrême la nécessité de couper
l'électricité pendant quelques heures
dans la journée si on venait en manquer
alors c'est un peu pour se donner le
Boro l'un parce que à Elisabeth borne
est mauvaise nouvelle et ses ministres
et puis à lui de rassurer mais je pense
que certains peuvent un petit peu
relativiser ce beau message parce que
c'était le même il y a quelques mois
juste avant la généralisation de la
pénurie des carburants il avait dit
exactement la même chose pas de panique
en appelant à la responsabilité de
chacun c'est vrai donc nouvelle crise
même méthode oui c'est un peu ça alors
il utilise non seulement la même
rhétorique mais la même méthode la
responsabilisation des uns et des autres
puisque ce sont les efforts de chacun en
matière de sobriété énergétique de
consommation qui nous permettront
d'éviter les délaissage c'est un peu
pendant pendant le on avait la même
chose avec les confinements si on est
sage on n'aura pas de délestage alors
une manière c'est une manière aussi de
se dédouaner de la responsabilité
politique la sienne mais aussi celle de
ses prédécesseurs en matière de
programmation énergétique et de retard
sur la maintenance des réacteurs
nucléaires alors résultat des courses
c'est une espèce de jeu de ni oui ni non
les coupures n'étant ni certaines ni
exclus un jeu qui laisse sûrement les
citoyens un peu circonspects voire même
oui inquiet et même moi je me demande et
même s'ils étaient pas un peu résignés
parce que les coupures ne viendraient
finalement que s'ajouter à tous les
problèmes auxquels les Français doivent
faire face en ce moment inflation
augmentation des factures d'énergie et
même peut-être des grèves dans les
transports au moment de Noël merci
beaucoup Emilie alors je signale que le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a été adopté
aujourd'hui c'est la fin des débats
budgétaires et la fin des 49-3 c'est
juste dire il a eu 7 au total si j'ai
bien compté et autant enfin un peu plus
de motion de censure parce que il y en a
qui ont été déposées par différents
groupes disposition est-ce qu’on entre
dans le dur maintenant pour Emmanuel
Macron et le gouvernement d'Elizabeth
borne déjà autant de 49,3 il faut le
dire quand même c'est inédit sous la
5ème République on avait des recordman
dont on aimait beaucoup parler et
notamment Michel Roca je précise le
propos et tu as tout à fait raison
Michel Rocard tient encore le record des
49-3 par législature ici on tient un
record par texte c'est sur un même texte
d'une construction politique chez Michel
Rocard
il faut le dire il est dans une
situation moins contingente puisqu'il
pouvait tout à fait compter sur ce qu'il
appelait les majorités Dolby et stéréo
c'est-à-dire un peu au centre un peu
plus à gauche donc on a ici quand même
eu un texte qui a eu beaucoup de mal à
être adopté et c'est pas très bon signe
notamment parce que ça veut dire aussi
que ces questions financières et
financières sociales désintéresses
complètement les Français parce qu'au
moindre 49-3 sur certaines mois et bien
on a eu des manifestations absolues ici
on en est au septième sur le même test
qui est quand même un texte d'engagement
sur l'année pour la dépense publique
sociale mais il y a encore le projet de
loi de finance et c'est pour ça qu'en
vous disiez entrer
il faut être honnête à priori tant que
il n'y a pas une démarche des
oppositions d'aller vers la majorité sur
un texte aussi important le délai étant
ce qu'il est la majorité sera obligé
d'avancer à pas de course et donc
évidemment de dégainer de nouveaux 49-3
est-ce qu'on entre dans le dur c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser avec ce
discours très tonton d'Emmanuel Macron
qui l'inaugure ces derniers temps avec
les pâtes paniques ce côté un petit peu
lent etc puisqu'on lui a reproché son
hyper président pendant le premier
mandat néanmoins son risque énorme et il
l'a joué à mon avis avec le carburant
c'est l'incohérence parce que je pense
que que les Français sont en effet en
train de se dire si on nous rassure mais
que ça va arriver quand même c'est quand
même quelque chose qui politiquement n'a
aucun sens donc je ne sais pas si on
rentre dans dur mais je crois en tout
cas que la posture de réassurance n'est
pas forcément la bonne en ce moment ou
comme vous le disiez beaucoup de
problèmes sociaux financiers
s'accumulent sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et où parfois le discours de
réalisme et de et de sincérité face à
des événements qui il faut dire sont
souvent très exogènes à la majorité
mériteraient parfois d'être un peu
martelé en terme d'image ça paye
Emmanuel Macron c'est le président des
crises et ce qui lui a permis en fait de
pouvoir obtenir les 28% au premier tour
de la dernière élection présidentielle
c'est la plus que ce qu'il avait obtenu
en 2017 c'est le fait que on s'est dit
il a affronté la crise des gilets jaunes
la crise covid la crise ukrainienne il
est pas paru d'ailleurs comme étant
comptable contrairement au moment où
c'était produit en fait d'avoir été le
déclencheur mais plutôt celui qui avait
dû se confronter à ces différentes
situations là il donne le sentiment
d'avoir une posture d'homme d'État et de
maîtriser globalement les choses d'avoir
un gouvernement dans lequel au sein
duquel c'est pas le bazar comme ce fut
le cas aux yeux des Français par par le
passé donc au moins il a cette forme de
de regard qui lui est qui lui est accolé
vous faites référence à qui par exemple
François Hollande
à François Hollande notamment mais
surtout François Hollande en tout cas
c'était parce que ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le moindre quoi qu'en fait on
est énormément parlé aujourd'hui il y en
a encore et ça arrive c'est légitime au
sein du gouvernement et on entend
quasiment pas parler donc en tout cas il
a cette image de quelqu'un qui est
capable de pouvoir tenir la maison et
savoir exactement comment ça marche le
risque effectivement c'est le risque
politique c'est il nous a rassuré il
nous a dit que ça allait bien se passer
si jamais ça ne devait pas bien se
passer il y aura forcément un retour de
bâton qui sera relativement relativement
important les Français sont prêts à
jouer le jeu et plus d'ailleurs que dans
d'autres crises notamment criskovid etc
et là ils disent surtout donnez-nous les
moyens d'éviter qu'on se retrouve dans
cette situation là et à l'heure actuelle
n'ont pas forcément toujours entendu la
manière dont ils peuvent véritablement
opérer alors on le sait il se il
télécharge de plus en plus l'application
en termes de prévention qu'en termes
d'action et de conseils voilà mais en
tout cas ils sont prêts à jouer le jeu
notamment parce qu'il se dit c'est pas
forcément que pour le collectif mais ça
va être également pour moi et j'ai envie
de d'éviter nos distillent de me
retrouver avec deux heures ou plus de
coupure d'électricité ça c'est le dur
sur le front de la crise énergétique
Jean et on va finir avec vous est-ce
qu'il y a pas le dur aussi politique qui
arrive avec une projet de loi sur les
retraites débat sur les migration une
réforme annoncée de notre système de
santé une autre de l'éducation nationale
bref ça fait beaucoup de choses il y
aura plus de 49 francs pour ces textes
là moi je crois que Emmanuel Macron est
confronté à un dilemme soit il est comme
l'ont été les présidents réélus il
remonte sur son avantin il est
jupitérien mais au sens du surplomb
c'est donc pas au sens de l'hyper
président c'est-à-dire qu'il prend de la
hauteur et il est un président qui
s'occupe des affaires internationales il
va voir Joe Biden et les autres et il
s'occupe de de la guerre de la guerre en
Ukraine mais il court là le risque
justement de paraître
des problèmes et de ne pas être un peu
comme le chef de guerre le président de
crise comme la l'écrit Jean-Daniel
s'il s'investit trop et s'il va dans
l'arène par exemple pour défendre la
réforme des retraites alors là ça peut
être aussi un grand un grand périple
politique parce que il va être un peu
comme ce qui s'est passé au moment des
gilets jaunes il va être le bouc
émissaire il va être celui auprès de qui
on remonte tous les problèmes toutes les
difficultés des Français donc il est il
faut jouer aussi avec le fusible que
peut être Elisabeth borne puisque les
premiers ministres sont là pour ça être
100% il est à mon sens là il est
vraiment dans un dilemme très très
compliqué sur sur un fil par rapport à
ce qu'il attend c'est à dire de grosses
difficultés ce sera le thème d'un
prochain débat sans doute aussi
passionnant que celui-ci merci à tous
d'y avoir participé